PHIL: Finally.
FEMALE SPEAKER: MIT grad
student, food lover, fitness
enthusiast, literature buff,
organic chemist by day, super
hero by night.
PHIL: Soon as my mother had
me, I was ready to go.
Came out of there, running
and jumping.
I haven't chewed gum since
I'm a role model.
What's that stupid train
in Harry Potter?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hogwarts
Express.
PHIL: It's a Hogwarts Express.
I just took my sweatshirt off
and it cut my forehead.
I found the photo of
Natalie Portman.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
Phil is weird.
PHIL: You know that Paula Deen
was married to James Dean.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What?
PHIL: A lot of people
don't know that.
You know what my favorite
dance move is?
Slapping people with my tie.
This is my hood.
Don't take my advice.
IKE: I want to take it.
PHIL: I'm going to sign up
for ChristianMingle.com.
The commercial says, find
God's match for you on
ChristianMingle.com or at
Starbucks like every other
self-respecting American.
MALE SPEAKER: Did you seriously
just end your
sentence with a preposition?
PHIL: I can't talk about
my personal life in
front of the students.
MALE SPEAKER: I love
you, Phil.
MALE SPEAKER: We
love you, Phil.
PHIL: OK.
PHIL: Tom Cruise says I'm
silently judging you.
There's a girl that was picking
on me at school, and
on the way to school I remember
trying to make up my
mind as to whether I was going
to stick my tongue out at her
or hit her with my bag.
I never felt so close to dying
in my entire life.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
a sticky bun.
PHIL: I can't.
I really can't
[MUSIC PLAYING]